when you have people call in you want
them to call on a landline but the
number of people that say I don't have
one anymore it's since to me I do I do
but I'm you know you're over fifty
school okay so I I texted this man to
say hey you want to come on and tell us
what the ins or should do for draft
night even though they got to smoke him
if you got him on first night address
you would do you do have a landline or
you ever sell or are you one of those
Millennials without a landline he
provided a landline and called it he he
said he was a grown-up from bob parts
abba Shola on CBS
none other than Billy Gardell the
grown-up here on the Rich Eisen show how
are you Billy Billy man getting through
it a day at a time like everybody else
in the science and doctors and math and
just trying to stay in that Lane not a
boy I'm glad that you're a mess with
this I can't mess with this virus I'm 50
I'm overweight I got asthma and type-2
diabetes it's outside looking for me I
got to be extra careful and I'm glad
that you're inside on the phone here on
that hard line not chat with me and and
figuratively smoke him if he got him
Thursday night the rare situation where
the Steelers have coughed up their
first-round pick although it was kind of
worth it for Mika Fitzpatrick last year
wouldn't you say that's why I'm
completely relaxed about that the one
did the one great thing about last year
was we realized now we have a defense
that can compete and and minka was when
I got a buddy in Miami who was Torchy's
a tortured Dolphins fan but he called me
when that trade happened because you're
gonna love this guy he's like he's one
of the few bright spots on our defense
and what he did man and I this is better
than anybody we could have got in the
draft the Steelers have gotten scorched
over the last decade in the middle of
the field any quarterback that that once
zone defense that knows how to play
against it would shred us in the middle
of the field Brady shredded us in the
middle of the field and I think minka
has taken that away he's not only he's
not only made it unsafe to go in the
middle but he's provided several
turnovers
I love his attitude I could not be
happier with that trade so I'm all for
that trade I think we're we got to look
I think they'll try to even tough in
that lineup even more than it is
although it's it's it's pretty electric
our defensive line again finally and
well you know when you got a good pass
rush you can hide a secondary that's
trying to grow and mature because if
you're getting to the quarterback ain't
got time to go downfield but if there's
no pass rush you can't hide anything but
I think that defense has come together
in a way that is very very exciting I
think we gotta go I think I think where
they'll look because they always
traditionally do we're always like we
always have 57 linebackers yes I would
imagine we're gonna look for a
linebacker or an edge rusher and then
they got to go after a running back we
gotta guard we have to I like Connor a
lot but he had the Pro Bowl season but
then he was banged up every couple weeks
it the way we play football I'm not sure
a fast explosive runner is the guy we
want I mean that might be a good change
of speed guy and I'm not taking anything
away from Connor I just think the
punishment on his frame and wait for
what we do is it doesn't match up and I
think it would be a lot better season
for him if we just got a big nasty hog
to hand the ball to Billy Gardell we had
we had Mike Florio of Pro Football Talk
on yesterday and he threw out hey if
Leonard fournette
on the block maybe that's the fit for
the Steelers again I know again but it
was so out of character for them to
trade up for Devin Bush last year and
then thoroughly out of character to
trade out of a first-round pick for Mika
Fitzpatrick in the middle of a season
certainly after their quarterback has
announced he's done for the season so as
long as you're out of character doing
that maybe you should be a little bit
out of character and go hop on Leonard
fournette I think that's one of those
things where we're you know progress
eventually makes you turn the dial a
little bit I love that they stick to
always a they stick to their number in
the draft they stick to finding players
like one of our staples is you you find
a player in the draft that comes to
Pittsburgh gets the program
we'll play so far over their head at
Pittsburgh that it's amazing and then
you know then they move off to Seattle
and you never hear their name again like
Chad brown but I do believe that you
have to kind of turn the dial a little
bit these days because the markets just
too in flux now in them I would love to
have forward Leonard fournette I I would
yeah that's what the thing I miss most
about Metis is if you had five minutes
left in the game and even if you were up
by two if you saw him come trot now you
could just relax you can you could go
build a plate of nachos because you knew
he was just gonna grind them into
submission and I would love to have that
guy I would love to have a closer like
that again that would be my ultimate
pick but I don't I don't know where
they're gonna go for that Billy Gardell
of CBS's Bob Hart's Abba Shola
here on the Rich Eisen show formerly of
Mike and Molly back in the day and
that's where we first met you and I just
love your fandom
Billy for those who might be new to you
as a die-hard Steeler fan let me just
walk through a couple of things that
I've I've just of our history okay um
our history you're doing that read for
Manganiello and you were just as I just
when we did it fell for you on the first
day bridge right back at you when we did
the live read of major league which was
amazing online about some white walls it
was amazing it was uh it was
unbelievable that night so back in the
day well just last year and your lead
pipe wielding professional you couldn't
make it on the show because your voice
was shot right you just you just went
all out against the Browns last year
when you went to high school that was
the home Browns game after the crowning
Rudolph got hit in the head with that
helmet yes you know look as a Steelers
fan of course you think the other guy
was out of line but as a sensible person
and a quarterback
probably not the guy you should just
start with and if you do make sure one
of your guys is standing in front of you
but it got nasty and it got ugly and
there was
away even without been that we could
lose that game in Cleveland and I was
scheduled to come to your show that's
the next day and I went to that home
game I even took my mom for extra mojo
cuz she's out of her mind too and they
let us do the Terrible Towel twirl and
it was a it was just a day of screaming
and then I I I know I called you then I
was like rich I can't come on the show
because I hate Cleveland and you said I
understand Billy we'll do it again your
voice your voice sounded like Tom Izzo
March Madness Tom Izzo like you know
like you can dive done that once before
during my komali I went to the Jets
Steelers playoff game with with when we
ding that and I'm not trying to bring up
bad feelings here but that that field
goal I'm home so scream died and so sick
that it cost us three days of rehearsal
from Mike and Molly and and then I did
it again
now I did it again with the Cleveland
game because I came home and then just
tried to walk in to rehearse and I said
yeah everybody and Chuck was like he
walked by and he put Chuck Lorre put his
hand on my shoulder guess no more no
more football game which was the game
where you let it when did you light a
candle in a church in New York City when
did you do that was that was the when we
lost that absolute heartbreaker to New
England when they flicked that ball over
the end zone and they said that Heath
Miller didn't have it I mean of the
taxon we lost that heartbreaker and I
was in New York City because I cost you
and I walked to st. Patrick's Cathedral
and I lit a candle for the Jets and said
yes and I said in hopes that you would
beat them because there was some crazy
scenario that if the Jets beat the
Patriots and 14 other teams won by two
we would get in so that's why that's why
I was like mccandless Patrick and this
is this is no this has got nothing to do
with religion how'd that work out
for you Billy how did that candle
sometimes God's biggest answers or knows
we end up you know I don't know
that's sad Billy Gardell what do you
think about Tom Brady The Buccaneer what
do you think about that one here's the
thing if if they can get that line to
not touch him he's gonna torture that
division and Bruce Arians is a great
quarterback guy
yes great quarterback guy and he's the
kind of coach that you kind of want to
run through a wall force so it makes me
it makes me I I'm not ready to make a
judgment on that till I see it yet but I
think it could be I think it could be
real interesting games watching Brady
and Brees go at it you know or Brady and
and and in that division at the Houston
game against him would be good I I don't
know I I'm nervous about it I I just I
wish the guy was just retiring I'm done
I've had all the Tom Brady's and a human
being can take so we're gonna have to
put up with him again I gotta wait and
see I don't know what's gonna happen he
may have some of that you know magic
like Montana had when he went to Kansas
City this guys are just not they're not
they're not on the regular chart you
know they are not they are not on the
regular chart so now that tom is in
Tampa ok and now that Eli is retired and
Phillip is on the cults and Brees has
been on the Saints for for a while but
he hasn't been on the same team since
the very beginning do you know who the
most tenured with his original team
quarterback is in the National Football
League now Billy Gardell
was probably been right it is that can
we put the photograph the most recent
photograph we've seen a big been up on
the screen Billy have you seen this
photograph I don't know what he's doing
he looks like he's been out in the woods
looking for truffles I don't know what
he's don't know if he's building a log
cabin or what just you know looks like
you went from this one it looks like you
went from duck Hodges to duck dynasty
frankly Billy he's looking like Uncle
Jesse from The Dukes of Hazzard I don't
know what we're doing there so I'm
hoping I'm hoping that that's just a
thing and maybe that's I'm growing the
beard until the arms at full strength
and then hopefully he'll come back fire
in the can and again that's what I'm
rooting for so you're not concerned
right now I don't think so I actually I
actually think he's gonna come back
strong and he's gonna be alright and I
think we're gonna have a great year with
that defense and if we can find a
running back I think we're gonna be in
the mix man I really do all right I love
it the glass is half-full
maybe you should go is with the Steelers
hey we go now doesn't get enough respect
I agree Billy your talk to your preacher
the quantum beat Tom Brady at his peak
twice in the biggest show on earth and
you know he's still sitting four seats
away from Archie at Thanksgiving dinner
and I don't think it's right I beat
Brady twice you threw wobbling ducks on
Denver to win a Super Bowl and beat
Brady twice in the biggest dance there
is do you want to channel that I mean
did Michael Strahan and Justin talk
deserve most of that Rainey wobbly ball
he was thrown Payton was thrown against
Chicago in that Super Bowl as Dominic
Rhodes like and twice you might still be
but actually Cooper's probably the one
that's right there yeah the oldest you
know I think that they they both look up
to their older brother like I once saw
the night where art you received the
Summerall award at the Pat Summerall
dinner
and Cooper was the one who went out or
Cooper as they refer to him went up
there and both Eli and Peyton they
deferred to their older brother just
like any old family so that's that's
older brother stuff there that's
probably because he used to torture them
when they were little punishment that's
been handed out I just don't think that
Eli gets the justice he deserve I got to
see Peyton Manning Peyton Manning has
more endorsement deals than a NASCAR car
just put stickers all over it he'll sell
whatever you have Eli does not get he
gets a g-shock watch commercial he beats
the best ever and we never hear from
them again I just think it's unfair this
is just the Steeler user anti Peyton you
got the ball bounce you're what you know
didn't bounce your way or you know and
Big Bang made the tackle of his life
you took out paint you know I'm still
didn't beat Brady twice on the biggest
show on earth
there you go that's Billy Gardell Sam
thanks to Carly didn't make no noise
went out there and beat in place you're
the man Billy thanks for the call stay
and stay safe and enjoy the draft
Thursday night we'll see everybody let's
enjoy the draft because that's all we
got right now I'm excited I'm excited to
just get a trickle of sports we're gonna
give you a big a big a big night of the
draft Thursday Friday Saturday and all
that good stuff you take care yourself
Billy man I love that guy he just makes
me laugh hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here